there's a movie that was awesome
you know who uh you know who are the two
most talented people in in Hollywood
ever
and I said this and I said this with
another guy Jay Moore and Will Sasso
Jesus and Will Sasso agrees with God
so there you go argument here too Irish
kid Irish kid I haven't seen him a lot I
miss you how is Meredith
he's a giant no he's been hitting
baseball
stuff can can I can I see can I get a
picture please yeah my son goes to bed
like this chain
it looks like Cecil Fielder he made his
son he named his son girl names Meredith
and what's what's here on this one
it's like this how old is it it's 12.
you're all seven pounds
isn't it great when they get into
baseball in my head my son like no CT
yeah
like you're wrestling when you like it
or not he's like no
like you can already throw an arm bars
from Jersey we're in Jersey
Corona
I got a head like Bill Maher
is it show on his nose
this is really the fighter in the kid
come on baby
oh my God you're so busy
you you said I heard you say you were
tired somewhere along the line
what me you today no you told me you
retired the last time you talked you
were like I'm semi-retired from show
business I thought you're saying tired
which is a crime or Pam but him you're
tired
he doesn't either well we're not allowed
to have a good time
you sound stupid right uh I think I was
joking Brian when I said that
you know I never know when you're
serious it was just one of those days it
might have been one of those well like
I'd like to retire sometimes and do one
stop at all yeah that's a good point I
had a hell of a weekend because I'm
shooting this show we'll do whatever the
[__] you want to do it's what you like
retire meaning I'm just gonna do what I
want to do what I don't have to do
but I I'm having trouble moving because
I boxed two I went to two Philly gyms
boxing gyms and and one of which was
Schuler's gym where Bernard Hopkins and
Julian Julian Williams train real boxing
gym like not a lot of white guys there
no comment but the point is it was so it
was amazing well well Percy custis who
owns Shores gym in West Philly we used
to be in uh um Frazier's Camp so you're
with these guys and I I get in there no
warm-up and just start hitting mitts and
all I want to do is look good because
I'm a loser now I'm sure you use the
lingoism you thought you were using a
little damn jiving baby some [__] well
you know what man what's up John what is
it I can drive turkey I can crack you
know what I mean and you get in the ring
with me and you can touch my jab jive
turkey they're like hey bro
what you think that right hand jive
turkey no no no no I don't think
anything oh we fighting oh we fight
you
walk into those gyms and they're so
everybody's humble and quiet and then if
you were to walk in there like they were
talking about how this guy came in there
and he wasn't real but he wasn't a boxer
I'm more of an MMA guy but he tries to
get in there in one of those gyms where
they only do boxing with like where
Bernard Hopkins and all those guys come
on and uh all they'll say is I go how'd
it go and he goes well you know guys all
he goes well you know one of those old
stranger he got he got he got touched up
a little bit you know yeah we you got
you know they're well because we told
him to move around a little bit see how
he's doing but he said I just want to
get in there move right away and then he
got he got touched yeah I said well how
long the last he goes he went home after
the second round
I was like God damn it was really cool
though it was really cool yeah I loved
it and I ate at uh Rouse which is the
oldest Italian restaurant in uh in
Philadelphia I mean in the United States
actually the Ralphs all the time oh yeah
I know that yeah did you ever go there
when when Ralph no I went to the place
do you know the place uh uh Albertsons
you're missing the point it's in Philly
no they're in there forever
Street the Italian last time not the
Super Bradley Cooper's favorite spot yes
but I ate there the last time I was with
him I love those guys at suplex whatever
Bradley eats I eat and you're we're in
Jersey from yeah Bradley's my favorite
Verona
we got Jay Moore
the great Jay Moore the great the
greatest The effortlessly Talented for
real yeah turkey
the LeBron James of Comedy if you will
LeBron well yeah not me
ran a child yeah
man he got touched up a little bit now
so good to see you buddy I like how your
setup is that one guy's always has
always has his back to the guests I know
it's kind of weird like this it's not a
good setup we should now he's making
faces every time you turn this way
put a mirror over your head
we've been knowing each other a long
time jamo you're not a bad looking man
Mr gas hey I do my best I'll do my best
we were fighting [__] ghosts out
there man that's right that's right yeah
Jay and I I don't know when we met
though I don't know did you meet at the
store before that I don't think so I'm
still not really like a store guy yeah
didn't you think the store was haunted
haven't I heard you say that you were
doing a second I was on Ghost Adventures
with this with my boy Zach yeah I love
that me and my son rolled up and it went
down like while we were filming it was
great I'm telling you this is real you
[__] oh it's haunted for real I
remember I was on stage Louis Anderson
used to do Sunday nights there and I
used to go
and I was doing a spot and we're
backstage and I'm like
reflex you know I was in rehab right
what oh
no secrets oh God no secrets [__]
rigorous
and uh I'm backstage at The Comedy Store
and I I look at Louie Anderson I'm like
man this place
[__] haunted I don't I never do well
here he goes no they like you the girls
that is to go stay like you just tell
them to get lost so I'm on stage
and this you know it's me and you
talking like I'm not gonna lie to you
six minutes not only did I not get a
laugh
the first six minutes there wasn't a
sound
this is main room yes nothing what wait
a minute and I'm looking at the audience
and they're like
like a painting like everything was
frozen and I feel cold all around my
neck
and after like four five six minutes I
go man get the [__] away from me ghosts
and The Crowd Goes
how high were you James I was just
before all that really yeah it was crazy
[__] you're really the ghost of the
store though they like you though
Brandon yeah Brian Callan the singer did
you ever
you ever see Louis cry on stage
do they have butter ever I like when he
goes low
Brian cowling in the gym in Philadelphia
he he did a set and he started weeping
on he was it was yeah Louie was great
you guys get to a certain weight that
their eyes
yeah he's crying about his mom how his
mom protected them from his abusive dad
on stage was it a funny bed or they
started out funny and then it turned
into a monologue I was gonna say it
sounds a dramatic Broadway monologue I
have Avenue wait no sentimentality
Trump's funny every time like you do
like a pretty good set you close or
something like you guys really mean the
most to me they all stand up yeah yeah
they love it yeah you just you do
something you know I couldn't feel my
legs yesterday
they're already in but back to the Ghost
Adventures when you did it with Zach
where was it at not the store because he
did one on the store no is it coming oh
you went to the store what about my son
good parent well and we were in the uh
we were in the belly room and also just
a slam bang [__] we all just thought
it was like an extra crew guy like
making his way and not you know you walk
out of a set you don't realize they're
yeah they're recording and you're just
like hey no no
you have you have two sons I know how we
met we met on your show I was a guest
but it doesn't matter it was that show
you did a sports show but who cares
married no another one
um
yes I think so what what uh you have you
have your son and then you have another
son two sons yes 20 year olds at
University of Oregon 20 year old
that's crazy right wow yeah and and
what's he doing in University of Oregon
besides but when it being an
All-American baseball player
haven't talked to him in a long time
Brian okay what's that thing about Louie
Anderson crying thank God you know as a
result as a result of my addiction I got
you it's called it's called the wreckage
of one's past does he know you're sober
now though you know pops made it through
yeah yeah
okay well I've been there I understand I
haven't been there I just know that
sometimes you don't want to talk about
some things and let's just move on
nobody said I've been there no you know
his 20 year old son
you have my 20 yeah my 20 year old yeah
you guys look great I've been there an
age right I've been there man
I trained a lot today this weekend I uh
I had time to go to Tijuana to get
[__] moose comb to rub on your
forehead to get rid of your wrinkle
that's exactly right you're the best you
look great do I I'm good yes appreciate
it and your gender-neutral sweatshirt
come on dude it's green it brings out my
eyes you get it at Target huh you get
that I got it off Amazon
for fourteen dollars I was like 40
and I got a bunch of them and you know
they don't wear colors not well yeah
they're at Amazon they're all different
kinds of beige they're all I know I got
a bunch of sweaters that way I haven't
worn one of them they don't fit right
they cut it's all about the cut guys
yeah where's my camera
oh we got cameras so how do you spend
your day what's going on yeah
Jay Moore
you know most work related accident what
acting
I'm in air you are good research uh
big movie who are you playing
uh I played Michael Jordan
I do uh
I play uh John Fisher the head of Adidas
you can tell like when I um really
you can tell when my drug addiction got
bad because I go from like you know
doing movies with uh Keanu Reeves and
Forest Whitaker and then all of a sudden
talking dog movies I understand and I'm
not even like a lead dog I'm a
receptionist at bark Williams yep
earlier I'm helping somebody try
something on a chewy baton
that looks girl right on you
actually really good you can't be honest
with you I believe he was a dog that's
good said it out loud and that's that's
one guy go I was oh and I'm arguing with
the director I'm doing it's just all
voice over and I remember I'm in an
argument with the director and he goes
let me tell you something
take this how you want to take it
I am the Orson Welles of talking dog
movies
[Laughter]
he's right I'm wrong I have a lot of
experience in this genre here's what I
do man it wasn't even your my world
wasn't even serious yeah well he's been
believable he wasn't even being a dick
like he knew like it's just like this is
all I do I am the Orson Welles this is
gonna work in dogs it's gonna work just
do it this way trust me I'm like you're
got it
why don't you ring the doorbell adorable
oh it's all it's just so many like
sounds like you had a rough weekend yeah
so many run on Capital R's in the script
oh God you're sorry
oh God I can't wait to see this movie oh
it's been out a long time it has can I
rent it well it was award season what's
it called I don't know you know what I'm
gonna wait till the book comes out but
but here's a big deal
my agent hooked me up because my the uh
my billing is single card on the main
so it's like Matt Damon Ben Affleck
Viola Davis Chris Tucker Jay more like
we're all just right there I'm like I
know I was here you know I was here for
a day right well you're you're you can
you're the guy who's as talented as
anybody ever I I this is a fact I've
said this actually and on other podcasts
you are as talented as anybody ever and
you when if you decide to you can do
anything literally anything most people
can't do that and so but but here's my
question about addiction do you think
that you're addiction
wow
holding holding
there's a weird way to get to that it
was a weird thing are you addicted
because you you hate yourself or are you
addicted because you love the sensation
I love to be high you do yeah we're just
talking about in there yeah
maybe those things can
I don't think I think I was born that
way because I always
I I always needed more I've always been
insatiable and I've always
felt that absence like that god-shaped
hole and I've always I've always
wondered what I mean my first addiction
was approval like if you're not
approving of me I'm not sure how to act
no no you know so my intervention was
actually really fast it was like eight
minutes because the fast eight minutes
in I just blurred out I go just so you
guys know I'm going because the fastest
way for this approval addict to get a
room of people going
to going was to agree oh it was just
complete it's only like two people talk
like I'm good the rest of you yeah but
also I knew if they read their bottom
line letters like if you don't go to
treatment I knew I would die a drug
addict because I would use at them
because I love to use at you what do you
mean like if I'm mad at you I go snort
Adderall in my bathroom by myself to
show you [__] like that [__] she don't
know what she's talking about and you
win I won I won I'm high so you so you
didn't let them read their letters you
said I'm eight minutes and you go okay
I'll go I was like oh because you wanted
them to kind of be like thank God it's
pretty hot
it's pretty humiliating to be at your
own intervention like you watch the show
a couple times and you're like oh yeah
and then you find out that everyone at
your intervention independently try to
piece together an intervention in the
past like going back like five years so
I was really the last person to know
that my life was a mess
and you know you gotta lie you have to
tell a drug addict a lie to get them to
their intervention like you can't out
think us we're always thinking so many
moves ahead in the chessboard
so the live mine was at my house the LIE
they told me well first of all I was at
my house let's let you know how much
speed I was doing that they had to trick
me to get me into my house where you
know my groceries are yeah how are we
gonna get them in theirs the guy was out
there [__] I was way far out and so you
spent most of your time just driving
around [__] just just you know just
making sure everything was all right
yeah just scratch off tickets and you
drive through car washes and amazing
yeah so the LIE they told me was uh I
was told Skyler Stone
he reached out to me and he told me the
next morning at my house that for the
podcast for my podcast at eight o'clock
in the morning I was going to interview
Wu-Tang Clan
because I had to make it big and I was
so high I I believed them I think about
the disconnect
I thought Wu-Tang Clan the entire group
was coming to my house Scottish Stone's
a genius at eight o'clock in the morning
I thought the eighth blackest men alive
we're gonna come real early and walk
into my cracker cracker house so I could
interview them to help them with their
careers oh my this was this was Skylar
Stone's uh Skylar Stone was emailing me
as Rizza and I gotta find it yes what
and he was perfect and he said he was a
genius he made up like um just how you
know I'm doing an email address I love
Skylar stone for the record and it was
like it was great he's great and he's
like uh so the email address was like
Shaolin summer like something like Wu
Tangy yeah enough do you buy and he's I
had Rizzo um when I had my radio show
jaymore Sports and I had rose on a
couple times and he's literally texting
typing on an email exactly like yeah
we'll see you Thursday Thursday
and I'm just like man frizza
you email like a black guy you're like
yeah one love you know it's gonna be
dope yeah yeah you just want to like
blind CC and other black guys is so I
like I worked with him on
Californication he's so like he comes
from a different world I was like how
many kids you have I go how many kids
you have he goes like this he goes
hey cause I lived that lifestyle I was
like and we were talking about how you
got to save your money he goes yeah man
I gotta save my money because we're
talking about money to spend and stuff
like that and he goes no I'm gonna
button down and I go yeah and I look
over and there's a there's a yellow
Maserati which is I don't know cars but
it's the best Maserati yeah and I go
who's crazy he goes he goes it's what
I'm renting and I go you know he spent
yeah I feel in bed style I drive a
Maserati yeah uh I will so wait so I was
well real quick I was with us my oldest
son at the Santa Monica Pier on the
beach where like the Rings and [__] are
and we're just walking around my son was
like three and I see Rizza standing
there first of all he's way taller than
you think yes he's like six four yep and
he's with this child like another
three-year-old like gorgeous and I'm
like oh [__] my child and resist child
if I play this right they're gonna play
right this is great I'm in we're gonna
be lifelong friends yeah you know and
I'll be on the album
and so I walk up to Rizza and I'm like
how about you I go again
I love you Jay I love you I suck Ghost
Dog four times dude and the last three
times I saw it was just to listen to
your soundtrack it was thank you Lord
that's peace that's God all right
and I go and I gotta tell you man your
daughter is beautiful he goes that's my
[__] son Lord
I pretended I had another child that I
couldn't find
I go I grab my son I go where's Jeffrey
Jeffrey I go I gotta I gotta hold on oh
God Jeffrey and I just start walking
down the boardwalk
for free
like he's not gonna hit a guy looking
for this kid no that's not [__] son
Lord
Jeffrey because we're Jeffrey my son's
like we don't have like shut up my
[__] son that's my that's my that's
my son yeah cause you never know I don't
know like he got heated like and he got
like Angry quick like like I wouldn't
think he'd get that [__]
that little woo face
do you have long hair or something I
don't even remember who cares it's like
I'll be like oh yeah
not that one that one oh [__] yeah he's
beautiful your daughters beautiful
that's my [__] son Lord
so I clearly Wu-Tang wasn't coming the
intervention yeah so I walk into my uh
all right with the [__] mic I'm
trying not to block my face I know Brian
and I how come Brian's is down here he
gets his whole face on camera I know
because my I look at the way I've aged I
took the a lot of greens a lot of
phytonutrients and no speed there it is
[__] like a wood chipper but
my fiance used to be taller
why is
this guy he said it I didn't you look
great
you gotta that's my that's my son
[__]
Jeffrey myself Jeffrey I'm sorry I got
it I got this thing
so I go into my podcast room my
producer's there
how's the mic
chin
it's great dude all right and uh
yeah like my producers there Skyler's
there and I'm like oh wow that makes
sense because he booked the interview
with respective deck yeah and rayquan
the chef I'm like where are these guys
and then uh must be late Genie was there
and uh my sister's from New Jersey are
there oh boy my agent Matt Frost is
there my buddy Chappy's there two of my
opening acts are there my landlord in
Malibu is there and I'm so [__] up I'm
like you guys you guys got to get out of
here wutang's coming over oh my God we
have enough seats in the room and you're
high [__] I'm like they're really fired
up to watch me interview Wu-Tang but
it's not that kind of party you can't
just crash a podcast like this oh yeah
it was high I never was not there was
not a moment of the day I wasn't
incredible and then I saw the
interventionist and he was a skinhead
you know once you do a lot of meth you
never really lose that look yeah like
the bags the [__] Vans the Metallica
t-shirt cut under it really skinny they
always got the dangly cross earrings
tattoos of pit bulls on his neck and he
had a swastika tattooed to his head so
I'm like I don't think he came with
Wu-Tang then
this guy had no teeth oh God none and
he's like crazy he's like just leaning
into me like these people
I'm like uh
I'm not gonna love you to death now
this is also the guy from the gym Brian
was that he got touched up with him
that's not three Minds to work
to work you know bro
he's flipping people into rehab for
money maybe it's a business form so when
do you realize it's that's when you
realize
yeah
hell yeah yeah
by the way
by the way I've known that I would have
reached out I just had no idea I would
have I would have been like hey you know
I don't know what to say but I would
have called you yeah I went to an all I
had no idea but nobody knew right well
no because it's we do it in private yeah
you know but I was told like
you know Matt Frosty my idiot my Frost
he's like no I'm I can't put you on the
road anymore like the
you know those little comment cards or
comedy clubs yeah it's a little golf
pencils a little mini golf yeah you're
like nobody fills those out or they'll
say like you know Gabriel Iglesias yeah
just write like one name you're like
yeah he's coming next week
funny
so that that weekend I was in Tempe they
all every show they had like many cards
filled out like this is
uncomfortable really I'm looking at a
drug addict I was all sweaty I was
missing teeth I couldn't remember like
punch lines I was mixing up Impressions
and [__] and I got real irritable with
the crowd and they're like we're
watching a fallen star
and uh that that [__] me up because I
thought the weekend went great
I made 14 Grand and I spent two nights
with a hooker named meow meow
meow meow I don't know if that's her
real name Brian what I don't know I'm
sure her driver's license
probably the middle name but keep going
it's just that's the Hernan the plume
yeah yeah and I you know I really like
that was I was bawling yeah like
everybody it was everybody else's
problem yes but then I learned you know
you learned that it's me it's I'm I am
the reason for every single problem I
have in my life and I was relieved to
know that because if I know that I'm the
problem I always have a solution did you
uh find any spiritual
sort of Outlet God anything like that
bronze religious no on the way here on
the way here now when you saw my face
um but but but does that is that part of
the recovery you're so on brand I know
bro oh yeah that's the only like that
god-shaped hole the only thing can the
only thing that can fill it is God and
it's like if you but it's so
it's a spiritual sickness and there's a
spiritual solution and it's if if you
want to get rid of the word god it's
it's you just have to get out of self
you have to give the day-to-day
operation over to something else a
higher power like if you don't believe
in a higher power they say go stand in
the ocean try to stop the waves
you know people oh you're making my
doorknob yeah but you better get off
your ass and turn it yeah like you
better go do some action but I have to
get to God before my mind gets to me
every morning I gotta just as soon as my
eyes are awake I just do that slide out
of my bed onto the knees this is
recovery is the only thing I've ever in
my life given 100 to and that and it's
the greatest result of anything I've
ever done in my life you like yourself
so much more right it's incredible like
I've always topped out of like 85 effort
like acting stand-up girls thought
everything was 80 my maximum [__]
effort where I'm like
[__] it was always a I always had 15 in
the tank because if because I'm a coward
and if I fail doing that 100 I don't I'm
not gonna be able to live with myself
but also if I succeed doing that 100
percent
then you're going to really look at me
and examine me and I don't know who I am
and that scares the [__] out of me um
success and fear of failure like I
either feel better than you or I feel
worse than you but it's a constant it's
not like one day I'm like this all day
it's situation to situation situation
situation and I learned in recovery
every single thing I did was so that
people would approve of me and like me
like why don't I do a podcast anymore
because guess what I don't give a [__]
at all but I just was so with everybody
was doing podcasts I'm like I can do a
podcast I can do one where you guys
going it's like your freshman hanging
out with seniors on the way home from
school like what are you doing I can do
that you I'm gonna show them how good I
am at it it's like just [__] relaxed
dude yeah but see what I think is really
interesting is when somebody talks this
truthfully you never look bad like
you're saying all these things about
yourself and you can just never look
back because you're just telling the
[__] truth
yeah but it's also like all of us I
think identify with a version of this
now some people have it more extreme but
I actually think everybody has some kind
of an addiction now it could be a good
addiction or an addiction I would say
that that has better results but it does
feel like as you mature part of wisdom
is coming to terms with all those
addictions or coming to terms of what
what causes that addiction
I definitely have a drinking problem
what was the question
you're doing great and the most
important thing is but you've been
you've been sober how long you say now
two years two months since uh 808 days
17 days is that what you remember it
yeah my man I do dude no I'm proud of
you it's [__] hard not really not
anymore right I mean I can I [__]
move Jesus
that's right because this is an
intervention like I'm against the cage
yeah uh I just did it alcoholically I
just did recovery the way I with the
same um
energy I chased drugs like it's all I
thought about and like every all I did
was pill math all day do I have an off
or am I getting the next one do I have
that prescription are they going to meet
is that doctor know about this doctor
because addiction becomes chasing the
nights wow Bill how long did you have
that going on I mean I was five years
from start to like rehab
but the last like two years like I lost
jobs like other people lost their jobs
because I lost my job like that's a
weird like if you guys get [__] canned
because you're [__] up like they're
out of work he's out of work he's a yeah
like that's not cool no like my radio
show I got fired from the NASCAR Awards
well I didn't get fired I just was asked
not to come back for an eighth time so
obviously it was going well
for a long time yeah but I remember I I
mean you just can't differentiate
fantasy from reality I remember I was we
were in Vegas in a writers meeting and I
had a nurse come in and give me an IV
in the writer's room because I kept
having cramps because of you know it's
like ah the worst cramp and I'm just I'm
just [__] sitting there like on an IV
drip like in a writer's room like like
this is how much work in here means to
me that I will but no that's not why
today you just told me that you you had
this whole addiction with Adderall oh I
told you before no but I know but I'm
saying today you just said you know
today you were saying it's about Jake
yes awkward but you said you kept
interrupting you were interrupting all
the time we were doing a podcast
remember that like uh six months people
were always saying that to me and I I
didn't know what the [__] was going on I
didn't know you were on Adderall no one
did right but you were you would you
would constantly listen to me right but
you would constantly never understood
what was going on I wish no my you my
wife she had no clue until she was doing
the laundry and she was I was telling
him that she was doing it because I
before I do stand up I had to have the
pills so I would wear these jeans I'd
have pills here here damn and then you
forget because you're going through and
she was doing
they fell on the floor my kid's like oh
candy I'm like nope was it those jeans
like for a bit what you wear those jeans
like for a bit yeah
yeah I didn't know I never knew anything
that's my stage voice apologize but then
like uh what okay was I quit once how
long were we on Rogan because I finally
brought up on Rogan wrong no you and I
had that talk out there because I didn't
know what the [__] was going on really
really Ryan saved your life is where
he's going with this no I didn't I just
didn't know what was going on with him
because he was more and more
disconnected yeah he was interrupted
constantly he wasn't listening he wasn't
taking the stories I could tell I would
I would say something he wouldn't even
hear it he'd just move on I was also I
was I was in present I was also kind of
mean like I didn't give up the [__] yeah
I was just go I never saw the mean I
just saw you totally hit you a few times
but yeah you struck me yeah yeah it's
interesting like it's it's it's a super
isolating drug like you just you do it
in private it's not something you share
it's very monetized and itemized like I
know how many I have left I know I got
this flight I know I gotta land there
I'm not sure where the hookup is but you
get really uh aggressive and you
interrupt a lot and it's constant and
you're in your head so I don't hear a
word you're saying because all I'm
thinking is that what I just said makes
sense wow and you're seized up we were
talking about like just riding the break
out of red lights just like having to go
I had to go through breaks on my car
just from [__] dude I marry all the
cracks in my teeth yes my other dentist
was just cracked his teeth and I was
like yeah it's gonna stress
God damn man
he's missing it dude yeah I mean people
I was W and like nobody knows you're
doing it no like you were saying and
like or you didn't know he was doing it
nobody had no idea his face would be
swollen but but they just thought like I
was [__] insane because I would be so
irascible
and then you'd be like not you but
somebody be like bro like are you all
right and I'd be like I'm fine what the
[__] then I go and use more because I'm
bent out of shape by what you said then
the next time you see me I'm even more
frenetic and then you're like I don't
want to hang out with that guy anymore
I'm like so he's just this this space
keeps happening until you're by yourself
and you're completely you want Adderall
when you try to Sprint Chappelle oh yeah
so so the he I'm he's good I'm gonna
erase you and he's 40. I go I'm like
please don't Sprint I go please do warm
up please warm up he goes like Zay then
I got this right in my face he goes I
got this I'm like oh yo shut the [__] up
I was like what I go you can't just
start running on concrete you we've been
sitting and he goes no I'm gonna beat
him in a race and I'm like this is so
[__] weird Chappelle did arrest him
did he yes he did who won I blew out my
hand he blew out his [__] hands both
hamstrings he had to lie down we had to
get a car and get him in the car and
drive him here
oh yeah it was so bad I could have made
fun of him but I was just like
something's wrong here I couldn't figure
it out it's amazing like as you get
older you ask if the person's okay then
you laugh when you're a kid you're like
are you okay
seriously okay so how long were you
doing Adderall uh probably six months
hardcore yeah I mean hardcore for me but
also I wasn't to the point like Jay was
like I was able to be like you're going
down a bad Road and I went cold turkey
right but then I was telling him you
don't realize there's like a a lag
because your brain's so used to that
that medication that when I was like I'm
a stop stopped on a Friday at show
Saturday and Sunday then Monday went to
do the podcast and your brain just it
can't function of it so I was flubbing
my words sometimes I would do a podcast
and I'd get done if you someone's like
what'd you just cover couldn't tell you
no idea jeez you know I'll tell you we
were talking before you got here like
when you do stand up it's like you're
just throwing railroad ties in front of
a really fast moving you're the
fast-moving train and there's like this
this other spirit that we all have in
our business that you just [__] toss
and railroad ties right in front of the
train and when you're on Adderall or
when you right when you get off Adderall
that guy's missing and the Train's still
it's like
you just keep hitting that ditch I gotta
piss go piss it's all good is it okay
we're not live
guys hate going to the doctor okay also
you don't want to talk to your doctor
about certain issues well here's the
thing most men Health most men's health
issues have very simple Solutions Rex MD
is all about Simple Solutions dude
vibrancy Alice is so expensive you have
another alternative yeah I do because
they make generic Viagra and Cialis okay
and they deliver it to your door yeah
yeah was it like 90 a pill dude no how
about how about it's two dollars a pill
wait and that's generic Viagra for as
low as two dollars a pill yeah and you
don't have to talk to a reception
embarrassing kind of conversation you
fill out a quick medical questionnaire
on their website a doctor will review
your situation and prescribe your
generic Viagra if appropriate your
medication gets shipped right to your
door with free two-day shipping it's
fast simple cheap you can access your us
license Rex MD physician anytime you
need afterwards Rex MD has helped over
300 Bros 300 000 Bros guys get generic
Viagra quickly convenient works on the
first night take advantage of their deal
by heading over to rxmd.com fighter our
exclusive deal with will save you up to
90 off where you'll pay as low as two
dollars per dose of generic Viagra
instead of 90 Plus on Viagra starter
packs or generic Viagra or Cialis both
are now available for our listeners get
started okay that's
rexmd.com Fighter for up to 90 off and
free gift okay partner well thank you
the show is sponsored by betterhelp is
it whatever man you take care of your
body it's fine take care of you gotta
get a mental sweat too you got to take
care of your head you got to take care
of your thoughts you got to learn how to
talk to yourself and sometimes that's
not enough sometimes talking to your
friends isn't enough sometimes you're
just two in your head you can't lift
some things down oh man therapy can give
you tools to find a more Balanced Life
all right so you can keep supporting
others without leaving yourself behind
look if you think of starting therapy
give better help a try today it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime you want for no additional
charge find more balance with better
help visit betterhelp.com
fighter today to get tempson off your
first month that's better
help.com fighter
back to back to things here it's a full
disclosure when we were in the bathroom
together I fake peed
nervous yeah well not nervous we both
farted together yeah it was good we had
good starters together we bonded over
the big fart okay but uh it just wasn't
coming out and then when you were done
you were just kind of not hanging out
that's weird no but it was like you're
just like ah you're like I'll I'll cheat
a step and a half if he's done we can
walk back out together so I'm like yeah
just two guys peeing
you got you got a little gunshot
approval addict I'm like I don't want
them to think I can't pee [__] big
shot are you getting better at the
approval addict stuff yeah
yeah
all the success you've had though too
that's right does it no it doesn't
matter
you know when I got
into recovery
it actually served me really well
because like I got sober out of spite it
was it's like oh really that's what it
comes okay watch this if I got to be
sober I'm gonna sober all you
[__] what's this
and then I got a sponsor and
I was like is it so important for to me
for him to think I was like the best
so I did every [__] thing I checked
every box that you should go to meetings
early and take a commitment so I'm like
on it
I'd go early and I'd sweep out the
goddamn Clubhouse I'd bring my vacuum
cleaner from home to tidy up but not out
of like
Circ it was just circumstance not virtue
because I knew eventually he'd roll in
with some other Old-Timers and in my
mind he'd go there goes the greatest
sponsee that I ever lived goddamn there
it is but as I did more crap more things
I did like that to get everybody else's
approval I got my approval because I
started acting in ways that I approved
of like hey I heard this guy's in the
hospital he lost a toad of [__]
diabetes it's like well I'll go visit
him see if he needs anything
okay my dad died we're gonna have a
memorial where you come yeah sure of
course but that's all the guys I heard a
guy say in a meeting once I've always
been a copycat just these days I copy
the coolest cats that's a cool line yeah
I was like oh [__] damn man so like the
guys I copied like that's just how they
roll yeah like just giving they're just
givers being good people just not
selfish I gotta tell you something I
heard last week of one of the best
pranks I've ever heard in my life do you
know Robert russler no you don't Maybe
Weird Science
Robert rustler his in-laws live across
the street
from you
oh I love Robert Robert I love Robert we
don't sound like you because I know I
know Robert very well
I was just thinking about Robert because
he worked on the Goldbergs with me I was
just thinking about it when you said the
story he's such a great mother touching
your arm fine
so he if this is true one of the best
pranks I've ever heard of in my life I'm
over here
well you're a dominant you're you're an
alpha how about Google Memorial Day
nothing for Memorial Day just gonna go
blank
OBG QT rainbow and everything but
Memorial Day just blank okay
Okay Google keep using Google you [__]
and carry on what should I use Bing
uh Duck Duck Go probably what's that now
Duck Duck Go I love that app yeah
what's Japanese holding well talk to me
talk to me about this is great radio
talking about visuals Japanese folding
it's
bookmarks don't worry about it tell me
tell me about Robert so he said he did
The Goldbergs with you and you went home
and then he went home sort of the same
time and he you didn't know that his
in-laws lived across the street from you
so you get home 10 minutes later is this
true rustler knocks on his door and
Brian come to the door and Robert roster
standing there he's like hey he goes hey
he's like what's up he's like nothing
he goes what are you doing here he goes
you know I just
thought we Vibe downstairs yeah I
remember this
you know it just so I'm shooting my shot
Brian's like oh no and he goes you
[__] idiot man
he was directly across the street got
great kids he's just so Robert's a guy I
just thought we Vibe downstairs
he's just so at home being himself
because I feel like he's been through
the fire and he spends all his time
being a sponsor for other people and
that's talking about approval I was at
his house once and his two sons were
there
and one of them wrestled at Samo
and I had a Pally wrestling they're like
did you ever go to Pali I go no I'm from
New Jersey I coached there and they're
like you coach it Pally I go yeah they
go what's your name I go Jay and in
front of wrestlers his sons go oh you're
coach Jay and I was like I'm in that's
pretty cool I could I could exhale like
I've been accepted by the seniors that's
awesome that's cool are you still
coaching there no I went to rehab right
all right that's right how long were you
in rehab you'd be doing both you're
right two months two months yeah I went
to one I went to an all men's Christian
rehab beans rice and Jesus Christ
I was in there with like 18 year olds I
was 50. they got like crazy
Fruity Pebble Vape hey
humbling can you have coffee in rehab I
heard you can't not after lunch they
don't they take it away so it doesn't
trigger the mess people so I'm like yeah
but not having coffee might trigger the
[__]
[Laughter]
but you have it in the morning
yeah and you know
my roommate in rehab did 11 years in
prison for arson and man his name was
Armando wow and if you didn't roll the
yard he would correct you so I remember
like I'm just at it I did five days of
detox where I just I couldn't keep my
eyes open that sounds like the worst
part wait so tell me about before you
get in there what's that like you're
just no you go from doing all the drugs
she's doing so your adrenal glands no
dude remember those old equalizers on
stereos all the [__] knobs on that
old stereo yeah you know it's just you
go from
so six days of what was that you just
couldn't I just slept and God came
downstairs to eat and [__] rehabbing
detox addicts loves to watch TV with
closed captioning on really they're
always reading TV I remember like just
the Dark Knight just being red across
the bottom of the screen I was in there
with a fentanyl addict bro all he
watched was The Dark Knight and the
fourth day I come downstairs and I'm
like you figure it out yeah and he goes
no
so keep reading he goes oh
yeah did you figure it out yet no yeah
man what's the hardest thing to come off
of do you know I guess I think all the
stuff yeah so my interventionist was so
mangy looking with the no teeth in the
skin when he this is true when he took
me to detox they thanked me for dropping
him off and they took him by the hand
they go we'll take it from here and they
pulled him inside and they closed the
door and I heard it lock and I'm like
I'm in like Temecula and horse country
on the end of this like half mile
driveway and I'm like oh later [__]
and I start kind of backward jogging
away from the house but I'm like I don't
know where I am and he's my ride like I
have no idea how to get out of here I
was [__] you know so they figured it
out and they brought me in and then um
detox is just you know they feed you
give you you know medications so you
don't have seizures and stuff from
coming off it
just kind of like a baby I could still
feel the air from that like it was so
profound like just you're so PR just I'm
just coming off draw in rehab too like
the biggest lash I've ever had in my
life playing [__] Scattergories with
a bunch of meth heads oh it's incredible
18 year old meth head celebrity uh
starting with an R
like no starting with an R that's what I
stand for
so when I got through that works all
right that's right all right you win you
got it but but my Armando
like I'm you're crispy dude like when
you get into rehab you're coming no one
gets there on a winning streak right
like you're [__] your life has come to
this they take them away death take the
laces wow out of your sneakers you can't
hang yourself with your new balance or
others oh yeah
so like it's come like the standard
stand in line for meds let me know where
your ego's at standing in line of like
14 guys like
is she up there that little half door
for the nurse to put your [__] meds
you're standing in like One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest yeah that's where it's
at that's 50. after all the success and
all that [__] you just like
and I treated it like how I imagined
jail would be
like I just [__] look straight ahead
I didn't sit with all about those in the
rehab and like I just said to myself and
to get recognized I know on the fourth
day they're like hey fool you come sit
with us and I was like okay did they
know who you were no they're like you're
a comedian you ever come out on their
YouTube
a couple times you ever come out on the
YouTube a couple times but could you uh
can you call your uh could you call your
fiance at the time or no phone calls
either no you're shut down
for like you're on like a lockdown where
you can't make any calls or anything and
then you get phone privileges for like
20 minutes on a Tuesday between like six
and six thirty but you're just you're
not that eager to reach back out like
hey remember that time yeah yeah yeah
where I got my [__] life cut down to
size that was weird does your past like
feel like a like a dream
no do you think about it
I think more like because I just do
recovery like I don't I love talking to
guys in prison like that's where God's
been pulling me like that's I go up to
California men's Colony like those cats
ain't coming home no no
and they're like they're lifers yeah
they're like good to see you again I'm
like I bet so you go up to the jail yeah
and and these guys are doing life
sentences they want to get free between
their ears you know
so my life more to answer your question
it doesn't seem like a dream it's very
tangible like I lived it I know it
it's it's I can finally take stock of it
and go God damn yeah I did a lot of [__]
yeah yeah
Armando
he corrected me goes I wake up on like
my second day and these these Latino
guys they'd be up at like 4am cracking
open their Bibles like [__] with
yellow highlighter
and I go good morning Armando he goes
get a rifle
Armando I said sorry
forgive me
I didn't realize you were an [__]
dude you have a [__] hour a killer
that's what I'm working on yeah a killer
hour he was in prison for arson
manslaughter he lit his drug deal he lit
his drug dealer's house on fire and
killed him Jesus Christ and he was these
guys were all ganged up like they were
all real talk yeah and he had a tattoo
on his belly that said loyalty for the
set but you gained so much weight in
rehab when he left it said
how do you say a profound I guess are
some people that serve time in prison
like there's this this train at the new
gym I'm at nice guy skinny it's all
tatted up white dude handsome bastard
blue eyes
are my favorite keep going to hit Miss
he always ask me to hit Miss I'm like no
I'm good man he goes you always come
here to sit the bad girl yeah I don't
hit mitz then finally I saw my air one
and I was like hey how long you worked
there and he's like oh I just started
about you know whatever three months ago
were you doing before that she's like
prison
say I'm sorry would you say it was
prison and how long were you in there he
goes [__] man I went in when I was 17
I'm 35 now so yeah he was like you know
I did you know a long time 20 years yeah
20 years ago
oh you kill are you feeling my mess you
killed somebody huh if you're doing I
guess no man uh I was 17 got in the gang
grew up in Compton only white gang
Compton gotten some trouble you know we
were robbing people and they wanted me
to snitch on the other gang members I
refused to so they threw the book at me
I got 20 years and I go Jesus Christ and
I go can I I go looking back on it would
you have Finance she goes [__] yeah
because I did 20 years I lost 20 years
of my life of guys who never called me
once when I was in there and all of them
are dead now from getting paid I put
noodles on your books
don't say I didn't call you I put
noodles on your books I got you a phone
card
I like when Latino guys talk on the
phone real loud
in Spanish and hear like one English
phrase at the end
of LensCrafters
yeah Walmart John Wayne Airport
[Applause]
you're funny in your sleep bro have you
ever thought about writing a movie about
this no
why not 85 85 85 just I don't have that
100 effort I know dude movies take a
Honda [__] I know [__] a long time but
you should write a TV show about it I I
think one minute show yeah stand up to
the top like I do like when my first 20
minutes is about that
you know
oh my God and all that [__] so funny and
like you know you go to so many meaning
I gain so much I I had I was so fat I
had to write five minutes about how fat
I was like it was just your addiction
when you got out well I went from
coaching wrestling on speed
to just hurt sitting in meetings all day
where they serve cake
[__] because Adderall you don't eat
it's an appetite and you don't sleep
you're burning calories when you're up
all night just [__] hey that's my
family what does your health look like
did you get a checkup
no it can't be good
yeah drug addict tell them the answer is
bad you're not gonna see the dog got a
fatty liver yeah yeah looks like high
blood pressure and your heart rate's
through the roof thanks [__] right
I remember I went for my torn rotator
cuff and he gave me a shot I forget what
he gave me a shot of horizontal
something like that but a cooler name
and I remember the needle just went
straight in I remember just looking at
it like
that should probably hurt
I just looked at it see alcohol is a
little bit different my buddy my buddy
went to the doctor he drinks too much I
think that's the hardest to quit yeah
and he said he went to the doctor and
the doctor looked at him and goes but he
stays in shape you know
and he uh and the doctor goes you're
good
um LeBron's obviously a little elevated
huh yeah and my buddy goes
because how many drinks do you have uh
uh I think it's a week all right because
now let's start with a knight it was a
night
one two
doctor goes one or two huh
looks at his enzymes are getting used
one or two you think a little bit more
sometimes my buddy goes you want to do
this you really want to do this doctor's
I would this thing was wine though right
and then he goes he goes yeah on the
third bottle of wine when I'm shaking my
head at 11 at night and I know I'm gonna
finish that third bottle of wine and
maybe get to the fourth you know that's
pretty much every night and the doctor
goes so we know what we have to do I'll
call shows in often your liver and all
that in your blood but in your eyes yeah
well a lot of people will compensate in
every other way right so they'll protect
their addiction so hard that okay I'm
gonna I drink four bottles of wine but
I'm gonna run eight miles I'm gonna work
out for two hours yeah it's a world of
extremes it's a world of extremes well
well or it's a world of protecting that
addiction at all costs I didn't I hadn't
drank since 1998 but I mean I got clean
and sober March 12th of 2021 and I if I
you know I go through the timeline it's
like after I quit drinking I remember I
got hooked on NyQuil I was drinking
three bottles of Nyquil a day what
that's a weird one how why it tastes
like [__] great really I feel like being
underwater like in SpongeBob but you can
breathe like really pretty now
your Constitution is is one in which you
like being anything but sober it's
anything but myself yeah yeah but it's a
euphoric feeling is that what you're
looking for look remember like when you
were a kid the first time you get [__]
up with your buddies you're like this is
the best I never had that uh I don't
have I don't take credit for any of my
sobriety I don't I know I don't have a
concept I get drunk I do 10 milligrams
of Instagram of uh Instagram of
Instagram 10 milligrams control freak
yeah I don't know you like to control
every aspect you want to know where we
going how are we leaving what time are
we getting where do I sit what do I do
this if you drink you lose control no I
just don't like it are you Putin I don't
like the way it makes me feel somebody
will feel euphoric I get sick what'd you
get your Instagram prescription okay
well that's a good question
I scroll I'll do 10 milligrams of tick
tock man and I just I get great I think
that doesn't even affect me anytime I've
ever done blow I can do two lines and
stop where most people have to do all of
that you know I had a bed with Myspace
for a while no I did I was [__] up on
Facebook
Myspace was a real issue for me you know
so it was NyQuil
like three bottles a day and I went to I
went to AAA to get off NyQuil and then
like once the obsession was gone I'm
like all right I got it and then it was
just [__] pain pills dude twice two
different times pain pills oh yeah he
had that he had that issue you guys have
a lot to talk about I was I remember
look at him laughing I remember I'm like
the mild if he's the hot sauce on mild
sauce at Taco Bell yeah I was telling
Brandon before we came on like my
dentist gave me Vicodin once I was 40. I
never took a pill before and I took one
Vicodin
and I'm playing Madden and all of a
sudden I feel that [__] tuning fork
inside like oh I feel it and then I
immediately went to my guest he gave me
10 bike and then I went to my guest
bathroom and I put the other nine out on
the counter and I counted them to make
sure he didn't [__] me
eight and I better be nine here I don't
give a [__] if you're in Vietnam
call yourself a doctor [__] me on this
count what I mean it's not that's not
normal and how many vicodin did you get
into Vicodin for a while yeah
I remember an NFL player
I go hey man do you have any like Norcos
or anything and he goes I do
and I'd ask them once before and he was
living here briefly and I went to his
house
and he handled you know those enormous
GNC protein powder things yeah
he goes like this and there it was
filled with the yellow with the Norcos
Norcos Vicodin like without all the yeah
uh acetaminophen
and I go whoa and he goes here's the
thing
he pulls it back he goes if you ever ask
me for another pill
I beat your [__] ass and I was like
deal
you took the whole thing yeah
and and Norcos are without the
acetaminophen to your liver doesn't it's
just less so Norcos have like 300 325
milligrams of acetaminophen and then a
regular Vicodin has like 500 milligrams
of acetaminophen and Norcos are five or
five milligrams more of hydrocodone I
think sounds like a real attic over
there yeah I had problems with it too
that's what I told you oh yeah yeah
so everybody has an addiction issue
except for me and then when I got on the
Adderall that was like I couldn't I just
couldn't stop I know it was tough that
entertain the idea like you hear people
go like well I kept promising myself I'm
gonna stop tomorrow like that thought
never crossed my mind ever because you
don't think it's a problem
yeah I literally would not be able to
move unless I snorted and Swallowed at
all Jesus Christ it was like coffee it
helped me focus on getting more Adderall
were you drinking coffee too
sure it doesn't matter bro I was fishing
for my paddle board in Malibu
like behind Dukes
I'd be out there like as soon as it was
any light I'd be out there [__] just
ripped on Adderall and like a full joint
like because it would you know help me
paddle better good time wait did you do
it you'd smoke a joint and do Adderall
yeah
I had a psychosis I remember I was
paddle boarding out in the water and I
was really [__] up on outer rolling
weed and I had a complete mental
psychosis where Ralphie May
I didn't like see him but he was like
out here
and I could I could bring you to the
spot on the water that had happened he
goes Dave Moore if you got a bird on
your helmet you stink
and I'm I'm paddling going if you got a
bird on your helmet you stink like if
you if you got a bird on your helmet you
stink Playboy and I'm like Philadelphia
Eagles oh they stink
and like for 20 minutes I'm out there
going Louisville Cardinal it goes stink
thanks gamer
I'm just paddling having a full [__]
conversation with dead Ralphie wow wow
second you stink if you got a bird on
your helmet you stink
like Arizona Cardinals stink
stink
I just [__] naming all these Orioles
all right they stink and he's like Oreos
what a trip
you want to hear the best for Alfie
story I have yeah but I have to pee no
you gotta pee I know oh my God this
makes me nervous all these stories but I
I feel like I'm an Adderall I gotta go
pee dude I'm so hungry man I just wish I
had some macadamia nuts in my mouth why
because macadamia nuts are amazing for
satiety
on the table we have them all over the
table so during the interviews whatever
doing podcasts and I just stare at these
nuts I want them in my mouth I want the
dip macadamia nuts please don't eat them
on it these are already like open the
chocolate ones oh you can't I can't
they're the best look Max nuts aren't
just for the rich macadamia nuts aren't
for them they used to be they used to be
because they are they are truly the
tastiest most buttery delicious nut I
heard Elon Musk brings them on the
spaceship well if you want to if you
want to not eat a lot but just be
satisfied they're amazing source of fat
uh they are they are they they do all
kinds of things for longevity apparently
but look also the best Taste of nut and
here's the thing this is blood sugar
yeah the South House of macadamia is
deliver them so they don't cost a
billion dollars because they work with
96 South African Farmers right so they
make it easy to get to because their
brand is farmer owned how do you farm a
nut how do you farm macadamia nuts I bet
you I know how you just got trees and
there are nuts and you water the trees
and you're like come on nuts and then
that South African Sun got to be careful
of lions and baboons and things like
that
then you pick them probably by hand
mambas a lot of mambas
I mean by the way I'd wake up everyone
go let's get naughty we gotta get nutty
every morning oh let's get all right I
crack like this yep and if I say we're
lovers and I I stay home and keep the
the house you know clean and all I'm
like careful of them mambas
thanks buddy uh sweetie I'm gonna go get
the nuts out there and then in your butt
loving that
he's gonna beat that out but leave it
believe it but leave it and believe it
either way that's part of my that's part
of my morning routine let's get naughty
careful in mambas
shake them trees
you gonna pick those nuts I'm gonna say
I'm gonna hit the fields and work on
these nuts when I come back you're
working on these nuts
okay I'm gonna do that too all right
either way guys how's the Macadamia and
right now for t f a k listeners and
that's the code you put in t f a k t
fact f-a-k that's the code House of
macadamias.com
and you get a 35 it's worth thirty five
dollars a a box of macadamia nuts
namibian namibian sea salted macadamia
nuts from the namibian sea all right
from I bet they're nice no salty and
delicious the namibian Bay is
get yourself some nuts awesome
academics.com tfak your whole order when
used tfak is the promo code and then you
also get them sea salted macadamians for
free right now okay
look at all these posters about your
failed spin-offs
chin versus the kid
our failed spin-offs
just a bunch of [__] just [__] that
never caught hey let's try this again
one day at a time night time that was
bad you deserve better than that no no
it's good it's good uh give me a good
Ralph family story
me
Ralphie was opening for me
uh we're driving to Tempe and it was me
my buddy Walter was driving
I'm in the passenger Street Ralphie's in
the in the back seat we're on the 10
East just you know the whole way and
it's like one of those January rains
where it's just like holy [__] like
you're doing 30 and you can't see [__]
like whoa like typhoon [__] crazy and
then the rain stops and if you look to
your left you can see the snow-capped
mountains
and I go man that's what God looks like
and my buddy Walter goes it sure is man
and from the back seat here Ralphie go
yeah that's what God looks like
and then the rain comes again there's a
[__] 18 wheeler we're like God damn
then the rain stops and uh Walter goes
yeah maybe you're right man like that's
that's what God looks like man and I'm
like fine from the back you hear Ralph
you go that is what God looks like man
and then it's [__] pouring rain like
a half hour later and Ralphie goes there
goes God again but it's still raining it
was an intimate struck next to us
it's a big Donuts
we're looking up here and he's just
looking
at it that sure is what God looked like
in our blind spot so we didn't even see
him we're looking up
there go God again
you know when you laugh don't you think
you might you might have to go to the
hospital oh my God oh my God
it was Ray was it to pull over we did
believe
we went to a 7-Eleven
do you remember Eric what was his name
he died um got hit by a car it was a
drug addict real skinny kid really funny
Eric
um the [__] this door yeah remember him
yeah
I didn't know him he was an addict yeah
well stop drinking he was such a good
guy and a monster and he opened for me I
didn't know Monster beat me in Good
comic oh yeah incredible and a beautiful
soul Eric Williams no it was Eric I
can't remember [__] I can't believe what
about him dude so he uh
Jesus I know I miss you boys but he was
in you know skinny would wear black
shoes no mustache
sometimes I'd wear glasses or a size six
small feet big head nice bangs yeah baby
hands Subway he'd always get the the
foot long no it was the Hat this is the
series we're off center I wouldn't say
his teeth were crooked but they just
they weren't uniform I mean they weren't
like taking turns originally from Naples
uh but he uh he was not I didn't know he
was a drug addict on the level he was in
the alcoholic level he was like he was
kind of drug uh alcoholic where he would
fall asleep with a cigarette and light
the whole place on fire and stuff crazy
she had a funny story about him yeah so
uh I I'm so [__] I'm such an idiot he
goes you have a lot of energy and I go
yeah and he goes man how well Jeff what
I do I go well how do you eat because I
was watching him eat some [__] yeah I
know this is how naive I am so I go to
him I go no you like here we go again
with the you know there's certain leaves
you can eat that's what I'm saying here
but that's what I'm saying with my with
my [__] like nutritional wise dude
yeah so I go he goes what should I eat I
go I'm looking at his skin and he looks
like he's been burnt by the Sun so I I
look at him it's also the least of his
worries I know some people call it
sunburn yeah no this is this is just
alcohol then the DTs so I go and he was
sober at the moment and I go um
you should just try eating some avocado
and he goes what's that I go an avocado
it's a it's a fruit but it's a and I
explain it to him and I show it to him
and so he goes and that night that night
he goes I ate an avocado and I go good
and he goes it was hard to eat though
he ate it like an apple he never peel it
hey
well I mean just the out part the outer
part is true I go you ate the skin huh
because he ate the whole [__] I can't
get rid of various ghost veins he goes
yeah I feel better man hurt my stomach
okay
okay next time check with me on the
avocado
I had an avocado allergy and he ran into
traffic yeah
he just powered through though he's like
this is good for me I guess must be not
supposed to taste bad was he your
brother huh no no no white guy where was
he from you know we're in avocado
Florida oh yeah oh yeah my first week
coaching at Pali High
there's this kid he's just [__]
it just looks fantastic like we're all
doing rock and roll all this kid was
just doing Jazz yeah as a wrestler you
mean yeah yeah somebody's
and I go up to him and I go uh can I
talk to you for a second he goes yeah
what's up I go are you Varsity Eagles no
I'm Eric
foreign
I was like I don't want you guys taking
moves across your back you're not good
enough to pull off a gator roll you know
and I go and one day he does a gator
roll in a match at like Birmingham high
and he beats their senior he's like a
sophomore I go why do you keep taking
moves across your back and he goes I'm
iconic
that's great it's the best he texted me
last night out of nowhere I'm like hey
Ah that's incredible you Mercy nah man
that was her America
strong strong
as [__] I go then which ones who's first
the second I I want this jacket so bad
it was a starter jacket remember those
were big my brother still makes fun of
me today we went to put on me back to
school and I pull up in my cowboy
starter jacket this guy goes this is
star bag it's my first one yeah
the starter NFL Pro Line it's 50 bucks
next to the first one he pulled out
fifth one all right yeah
that first one
it took me a while to get it yeah
you ever lose your phone while you're on
it
yes
or it'll be in your hand you're looking
for it where the [__] is my phone what's
wrong I can't find my [__] phone
where's the last place you put it if I
knew that I wouldn't be looking for it
would I you're like let me call you back
literally what happened at the airport
I'm like where the [__] is my phone I'm
looking through my bag
it's always like when I'm on it what the
[__] is my [__] [__] I get angry
I get this one thing that gets manger is
that [__] my father I don't have time
for this bull [__] this [__] you
know looking through sifting through
pulling [__] out there you go when his
baby's around he says bull crap no I say
in fact they say [__] around my baby and
my my wife is like hey you got to stop
this [__] oh everything's cool I got a
scolding we saw um
I saw Jerry Maguire in the theater
there's like these black guys right in
front of us and there was a gay couple
right in front of us and it's packed in
Times Square right and uh I'm on I'm not
on screen for like 40 minutes and when I
come back on the screen the black guy in
front of us goes oh here comes this
[__] again guys smiley
okay smiley and the brother brother's
like mm-hmm
and then there's the The Bachelor going
with the movie theme the the bachelor
party scene and Eric Stoltz does a cameo
and the two gay guys the one gay guy
when Eric stole that camera the one gay
guy goes
and his lover just doesn't say anything
then he just goes
no
like they've been arguing about this
[__] for months everything is not Eric
Stoltz is that Eric's no
damn remember that movie look at you
[__] look at you young dumb and full
of calm look at that you were so good in
that movie dude oh so damn you were I
liked you in Wunderlist or uh the the
the the the magic movie
wow that was great you're so good in
that thanks buddy you did this I never
forgot it I know it's a weird thing but
like when you you've made the deal and
you go
on the phone yeah he just goes I ran out
of ways to act and I can show you're
happy because Cameron was like off
camera going More Money More
endorsements I'm like more money more
into it he was just like throwing [__]
at me to say he's like we're just gonna
keep it moving and then the the one I
just like ran out of [__] to say so I go
I go do you really know what Jerry
Maguire knows what it's like to be a
black person
like I made that up and the camera came
up to me and goes I want to show you
something and then it was later that day
after I'd gone home and they cut the
time and Tom goes he said that I'm Mr
black people
wait he said that what I'm Mr black
people yes like they showed Tom what I
was saying yes and that's what he like
he liked wow Tom was great dude hey
great person
[Laughter]
just the nicest guy in the world the
best when you're talking to him he's
like this all right you're like I'm the
only one it's like Dale Carnegie [__]
you're the only one that exists it's
incredible he comes up to my dad
actually said to me my dad raced cars
with him
at Bridgehampton and uh yeah
and he goes ask yeah yeah Dad's like
being a dick he was when he asked your
buddy Tom Cruise what Gary's in it
in the second turn at Watkins Glen
because you know he's the only one of us
that never crashed into those hay bales
I'm like all right
so like six days later I'm back on set
and I go hey you know you're racing my
dad at Watkins Glen and but he's like
yeah yeah
I go he uh he wanted me to ask you what
gear are you in
on turn two at Watkins Glen because you
never seem to crash into the hay balance
he's like
thank you
I'm like all right so then I tell my dad
and then like two months later we're at
Sun Devils this was at Sony here and
then we're at Sun Devil Stadium in Tempe
filming the football [__] and I'm on
like you know it's like two in the
morning trying to stay awake I'm
throwing a football with the guy that
played my quarterback
and also I hear JJ and I look and coming
out of the tunnel is Tom Cruise and he's
[__] sprinting towards me like it's
Tom Cruise running he's a great movie
Runner you know and he gets up and he
goes hey
not even winded
what gear was your dad in
turn to it Watkins glitch
like he remembered that [__] yeah like
he's just sitting in his trailer he goes
just came right here I had to hit him
tell it can you please tell the
Christopher Walken story
the tail the first time I met
Christopher walking on the set of
Suicide Kings I go to say hi to him and
the the first thing as I'm walking up to
him the first thing he says to me is you
know I can see you coming
I'm like
if I'm introducing myself I'm not a
Vietnamese sniper working a tree line
like a challenge no offense it's how
introductions work
[Laughter]
if I'm wrong
anyway
and he goes uh I had my Rottweiler
please do this podcast every day he was
just heavier all the time seriously can
you be a third guitar for real can you
just my heart attack time
can you just come on the podcast all the
time all right yeah I love it I'm
serious
jokes like you know please you know how
good it feels like when he does the
[__] leg Yeah it's my first one to
like actually laugh instead of the
podcast
funny guy you really are yeah wait keep
going so I go up to Michael uh and
before I say anything he goes you know I
can see you coming
and I just kind of freeze
and he go I had my Rottweiler with me
goes I can see your dog too
and I go her name is Shirley and he says
who cares
and I thought he cared because he
brought it up you know
and he goes I gotta know what happened
to your dog Shirley Rottweiler
what happened to your dog's tail
it's gone where did it go
it's okay you can tell me
and I'm just standing there like in this
driveway going
where the [__] is my dog's dead
and then he gets like real close to me
and he goes it would be great
I have a tail
and I'm cool right so I look back at him
I go why why is that
and he goes come on if you had a channel
everyone would know if you were angry or
upset they'd see you they'd see you
coming up the block
they say goodbye look at this tail he's
crazy
and I go well you probably mean happy
like people know if you're happy if you
have a tail you'd wag it because you're
happy and he goes maybe you in your town
yeah you just cut the ring off on me
right
and then he looked at me like it's my
turn to talk
and I've I've never had a tail talk
before yeah I look down at the dog and
dog's like nah not me
yeah
not me Edward
and uh would you rather be able to fly
or have a tail that's what I got out and
he goes a tail of course
I could rather have a tail than be able
to fly he goes you could always get on
an airplane
with your towel
so best Storyteller ever in the movie
he's duct taped to a chair right we
kidnap him and yeah it's like velcroed
in the back but if he gets up between
setups it's like you gotta unzip them
and this and then he's gonna come back
in you got to wrap him back up and get
his hands [__] duct taped to the
chair so he just stayed between setups
so I would just hang out next to him
like I'm not going anywhere everyone's
like going playing their [__]
acoustic guitars like and I'm like I'll
be right here yeah so I'm just walking
the Hall of Famer I'm sitting on an
Apple box right next to him I go what
was the worst part about
filming the Deer Hunter and he goes
this
[Laughter]
guy you just canceled him he just
canceled him if it's true right there's
such passion and expected that is
I mean spinning
get down there in a pit and the guy
holding the bounce card
goes oh we're down here
I'll be right back to it and I'll do
back on planet Earth
you know that is that's a Woody Allen
impersonation so I'm like all right I
had to take a leak so I go back out to
go to my trailer and one of the uh key
grips was was this Asian guy and he's
just outside having a cigarette and I as
I walk past him I see him I go Chris
wants to talk to you
just told me that
is duct tape to a chair and I send the
guy to go
even goes I had to see where I'm
supposed to cry and like okay we're
rolling he goes hey Jay
what's the name of the woman
who plays The Nanny
I go Fran Drescher he goes yeah
yeah I would like to bang her action
like
like you know what uh
There's a comic whose name I forgot on
stage he said he was doing uh he was
doing uh it was a movie that Scorsese
did and they were in the movie and he
said I he they were kind of hanging out
it was it was the rap party for the film
and Chris Walken comes in a little drunk
and he walks up to these new young
actors you guys
you know what's famous Fame is knowing
you could walk into a room and [__]
anyone
in the ass
that's Fame and he just walked away what
is the greatest
they were like it's true that's actually
[__] true okay Chris what are you
doing we're doing after this
when I was on uh here's the best rewrite
ever that no when we were doing on SNL
we uh by the way the old comedy Cafe in
Milwaukee on the Marquis at Jay Moore
from S Plus l
that was his resume
uh on the cast yeah I didn't know that
oh yeah
and uh we had to rewrite this sketch
with with uh David's Fred Wolf and David
Spade wrote it and it's like David Spade
was a weight loss Guru
and it was basically it was just getting
people to do meth
and you know like yeah ride the snake
and you know when you see like the the
outline of the fat person it's like
after six weeks and it shrinks like
after six hours six hours and then like
people have testimonials and they're all
tweaked out and then they had this film
piece where Farley's at a drive-through
window in his car and he goes yeah I'll
have
14 cheeseburgers and 14 hamburgers 14
chicken sandwiches 14 you know Diet
Cokes and 14 apple pies and 14 french
fries in the the guy and the lady in the
Box goes will that be all
and as it was written he goes no and it
was like TBD like I'm still working on
this joke so for two when I tell you two
hours at like one in the morning two in
the morning three in the morning coming
up with that joke like what if he just
repeats the exact same one like will
that be all no I'll also have then he
repeats the exact same order or no and
then he just goes make those Diet Cokes
or like no give me 15 Apple around and
around we went and then uh Norm
McDonald's we didn't know he was in the
room he's on a couch like at the end
like on the other side of the room he
goes hey you guys are talking about it
Chris at the drive through windows
cheeseburgers and all those french fries
you know and uh that was supposed apple
pies you know and then the guy in the
Box uh the gal in the Box goes ah would
that be all uh Chris says yes
[Music]
fell out of our chairs like one syllable
we were just dogs hunting in the wrong
direction he said sorry that's right
dog's not in the wrong direction and
then when they filmed it Farley had like
this sense of [__] Pride like this
drink this [__] mess already worked
like will that be all he's like
yes
that's the difference between Chris
making that choice
[__] oh Brandy used to be a fighter yeah
the only time I met uh Norm Macdonald uh
back to the main room of the Tommy store
and he goes uh you you used to fight huh
yeah he goes you uh you had any insight
on uh who's gonna win this weekend I was
like I didn't know he's the better oh
yeah degenerate Gambler oh yeah it
really is uh the other uh minus 230 for
the the tall fella I was like the tall
fella yeah yeah he was like all into it
and I was like why is he [__] so into
these odds yeah I never heard of
bookmakers they're in it for themselves
yeah and then Sam was like hey let me
talk to you he's like hey man that guy's
a degenerate game yeah he's like so if
you can give him pics Artie Lang said it
was the first time I'd ever seen a
hundred thousand dollars in cash you
don't want to see some of them coming
over all right he's like okay and he
goes yeah hey guys a hundred thousand
dollars and I'm giving it right I'm
going walking right over to my book and
giving it to him a hundred thousand
dollars he lost I love that already
story well I don't want to tell stories
not mine we've been down that road
before I love artists on Saturday Night
Live you're there how long two years
yeah addition you have to pass from
that's a [__] of a job right
if I could do it again I'd probably love
it yeah uh funny look at you man you're
the Dick Vitale looking for walking oh
my God you were there during the Heyday
I mean that's when big boys were there
huh yeah Kevin Neal that's a special
time huh that was Rock and Roll Real
Estate all right
that's a special time
I mean it changed my life wait wait is
that Jan uh Jan Hooks no that's my
winner Banks she was a Brit God I love
she was great I always had a crush on
Jan Hooks then how was your uh like your
audition process when I was at uh so my
manager Barry hey boss it's fair oh
Barry cats you don't want to make amends
to Barry when I made amends to him like
you know because of my addiction I did
this I did this and if I left anything
out I hope you'll tell me and I hope you
let me know how I can make it up to you
he goes
did you bring a checkbook
good old Barry I love Barry he's the
best the best I'm like no [__] dude no
let me get back to you man
Jerry would I mean Barry would call me
and go it's an amazing thing we've got I
got a great I you know they come out no
no but he was like you know Brian Kellen
the guy was always working you know
immediately I'm like oh thanks you know
and he's like I got a great thing going
on it's uh we're gonna be are you coming
to New England and you do a week of
stand up we have this whole festival and
the great news is you're in everybody's
house because we scream it and you're on
this channel and everybody has it in New
England so it's really good I'm like
that sounds great it's uh okay it's kind
of just a New England TV channel I'm
like I was like I'm just listening going
how what's the money like he goes well
so it pays 250 but we get your flight
I'm like you know how is never I have
never opened on my Instagram but so do
you want to do it so yeah yes yes it's
canceled
Brandon I have a gig for you it's uh
it's amazing
it's a
are you there Brennan
it's uh the Great Wall of China You're
Gonna Do stand up you're gonna do 11
minutes to stand up the Chinese
government they had thousands of
comedians to choose from when they chose
you I don't get it but
they're going to pay you a half million
dollars you're going to be on the cover
of every magazine it's going to be
covered by all news outlets you're going
to be times man of the year I say you'll
do it do you want it I mean that's
fantastic have you ever flown a leared
jet
I know
you've never flown a Lear jet no sir
I'll tell them
I wish he would be like famous famous
it's probably my best impression because
he was a father to me oh he's so great I
was 18 years old and a man walks into
your life that goes I'll handle
everything just do stand up you're the
best keep going keep going you build a
pyramid for you keep going man I said to
my buddy he goes he said to my buddy he
goes I love Barry and he was a good
manager but Barry would be like I'll be
I'll be the Jew I'll be your Jew who
builds a pyramid for you okay tangible
tangible motivation
you know he's when he was I really like
Barry I love him did you ever see when
he when he emceed at his own club and
I'll get back to the SNL is he still
alive yeah they're very kind of retired
he looks like Dirk Nowitzki pull him up
he has signed an autographed yeah he
made his money I think and I don't even
know if he does
I did a podcast with him actually give
me the Rock from three I'm white hot man
I always just really liked him no one's
wearing 41 can I wear 41. what's he
doing what is he doing do you know got
his podcast I guess
oh yeah that's right I love berry
undeniable man I was on the Jordan
Harbinger show was what I'm doing
he really is like quintessential manager
though oh it's cool like excuse me in
China he's still he's still your manager
no no he managed a lot of big big acts
like I I know I've met him or I know him
from somewhere
in uh Vegas during lunch and they're
kind of at the place themselves in this
big like skinhead that goes hey uh Dirk
I just gotta you know I was behind the
walls I just got out
you know I'm with my girl could you give
me an autograph we're big fans and
marigolds I don't know what to tell you
man but I'm not the whiskey
the guy goes come on man just be cool
man in Miracles I can't I'm not divisky
I'd be impersonating an NBA basketball
player I'm just a Jew the guy goes all
right the guy comes back again Barry's
like I'm telling you man I'm not there
so then like a half hour goes by and
they're having lunch and all of a sudden
he's sitting across from Dane and Dane
just goes
napkin
very likes turkey novinsky and he
doesn't remember his number so he puts a
happy face
the guy goes was that so hard he goes
not at all
oh my God
yeah
holy [__] Dane
wow what do you mean you're canceling
canceling how
yeah does he work with Adam too he he
probably Barry worked with everything
Perry works with everybody
when he would emcee he was fantastic
he'd be like all right
the comics are in the back they're
excited to perform for you they're in
the back doing breathing exercises and
Coke
just kidding they're not doing breathing
exercises
it's a good joke this guy's looking at
me like make me laugh you big blonde you
make me laugh oh he's like six six two
so people go there yeah yeah he goes how
about a round of applause this side of
the room
the people that hate me
and he had the best intro if you had no
credits he goes this guy is one of the
hottest comics in the country and you're
about to see why please welcome Brian
Callan it's great and you're you walk
out and they're like oh geez all right
so my SNL audition was at his Club the
Boston comedy club in the very own the
Boston Comedy Club yeah I didn't [__]
know that wow and it was in Late July
it's on the second floor above like a an
Irish pub with music the heat would rise
the air conditioner was out I went on
third I remember him coming with me and
goes you know in baseball your best
hitter hits third
by the way he called it the Boston
comedy club and it was in New York he's
a I'm a genius man okay why good
question so it was in New York I'm
opening up a hearing aid store it's
called LensCrafters
one punch line two jokes
I went on Third and the air conditioning
was out and everybody at SNL left after
the fourth comic because the heat was
unbearable but was it uh that that whole
all the comics were auditioning for it
yeah just based off stand-ups 18 guys
crushed 18 guys and they saw four of us
[__] and every guys went up they had no
idea there was just there was just no
one home and they're up there with their
[__] dreams and balls on the line and
everyone's out there just Fanning
themselves it was back in the day when
they would just come out and scout scout
yeah Scout stand up and then I had a
follow-up they wanted to see me again at
stand up New York and I was like this is
getting weird Carrie Hoffman I was like
I have no chance at this so I just I
went to the gym
[__] chest and tries
and I took the subway up and I'm in
sweatpants and like of you know Chapman
lacrosse girls lacrosse t-shirt and like
three AMP cell lights and everybody else
is in like you know when you taper the
bottom of your jeans like 90210 and they
had their funny shirts and their [__]
hair and I'm like oh I stand out here
yep because I'm just dressed and you
were the funniest and I did my whole set
I remember I did um
I did Andrew McCarthy
which is like that's how long ago it was
and then I did uh I did I did De Niro
and Pesci but as it but during but doing
Raging Bull but they were Batman and
Robin he's like when he stopped eating
you fat fat [__] you [__] bellies
hanging over the back belt you broke the
[__] bad boy you're a [__] mess
you [__] bad woman won't [__] you
anymore
and I just did that and then I did
Arsenio and I got off stage and the
whole time I did my good though you
might be the best I think will Sasser
said that I think you and Bill Sasso
might be the best to ever do it along
with the Frank Caliendo oh can we sell
some tickets God damn God damn though
you're good at that [__] YouTubers
dick in the dirt everywhere Grand Rapids
Michigan can't wait to see you guys yeah
uh I thought that the SNL people I saw
them like in the back right hand corner
of the room so like after every
punchline I like stared them down to let
them know like I wasn't afraid of them
no I thought they were in the back
that's what it was I thought they're in
the back left hand side of the room and
I'm staring them down after every punch
line and then I get done with my set and
I leave this way and I pass them on the
back right hand side of the room so I
spent the most important eight minutes
of my life staring down like a [__]
real estate agent from Patchogue Long
Island like
he's back there with his old lady like
what the [__] did we get us yeah yeah
[__]
don't leave Lauren wants to talk to you
and I'm like
like all right like I'm supposed to
foreshadowing you wait a lot and did you
want it yeah I [__] wanted it of
course Saturday night that back then
Saturday Night Live it was everything oh
yeah yeah Marcy Cline I remember
so Lauren spoke to me and goes and he
got in a white Limo just looks so
bizarre outside of Comedy Club
and then I went home and then the next
day I was performing at Catawba North
Catawba College in Catawba North
Carolina and it was me Anthony Clark
but at the time are you like a torn
comic are you a big comic at the time I
was like on MTV's lip service back then
nobody was a big comic because we didn't
have social media was traveling we
didn't have social media you always you
would dip the road but you have to make
a thousand a week which back then
foreign
to do a college was such a big deal so
so like you did nobody was making money
social media didn't exist Myspace didn't
exist Facebook none of that [__] so you
relied on the Legacy Media so when you
went to a town you had to wake up early
and do that media and that was the only
way people knew you were in town rape
getting crawl space when the child was
with us that's it oh I still have to do
it well tell us what's tougher for you
Bren fightinsight.com doing stand up you
guys doing any pranks on stuff yeah but
that was the only way to do it ads in
newspapers that's what happened so you
you went to you there was
yeah Jay Moore comedy for All Occasions
all that [__] so you couldn't wait to
get on Saturday Night Live yeah nobody
was making money you you wanted to get
off the road so you can make money as a
TV person yeah everyone wanted to get
this nobody made money yeah they were
like five one person two people that
made money it's so different that's
anyway Anthony Clark's like a real
skinny Southern comedian from Boston
though
and he's uh
it's just hilarious and he's we we're
like literally we're at a Motel 6 along
the highway in North Carolina and [__]
kicker Town yep and he's like he we go
to the pool and he's got that long like
skimmer and he goes like I'm gonna take
a swim
and I go well I'm gonna go take a nap he
goes okay
and I go to my room at the Motel 6 and
the phone rings and my first thought is
like well one of my parents died because
there's nobody can reach me here this is
nuts yeah and it was Ruth Ann sakondo
who was my agent that was my agent and
they're like are you sitting down and
she goes you got it I was like
oh yeah it was serious it wasn't like
yeah it was like holy [__] I know that's
right Ruth Ann gave me the call about
Mad TV so I remember this so well yeah
yeah it's like great greatest phone call
of all time so I go let me call you guys
back I put the phone down and I'm like I
had to tell somebody like
who can even conceptualize this this
feeling so I go down to the pool and
Tony's down there skimming the water and
the sun's behind me and I go Tony
I just got Saturday Night Live and he
goes
well there goes that nap
okay that was his response okay there
goes that now God Anthony Clark step up
to Lucky well sweetheart because I don't
[__] believe it what's he up to
just kind of laying on a pile of money
really he was hilarious yeah
Anthony Clark dude that's and then your
first week outside of my life because
back then it's like Sandler Spade Farley
Farley we had to get there early it's
like summertime like no one it's like
School a week before school starts like
if you know what you're doing it's weird
and I don't know what they're like I'm
like what time do I come in they're like
well you paid to be here what time do we
leave you're paid to be here
and I'm just sitting on a couch and Jim
Downey's there the head writer a couple
people like some Harvard guys are over
there and barley walks in to go to his
office and Jim Downey goes Chris where
you going he's like what he goes it's
the new guy Jay Moore and finally goes
hey how are you
and I'm sitting on the couch
during the month during the mic welcome
I just have Farley's [__] head in my
lap like and he was a beast that's funny
most beautiful man I ever met in my life
he would do this apparently I I can't
remember who told me but he'd be in
they'd be taking a pee at a ball game or
something and you just hear him go that
[__] it burns it burns that [__] oh it
burns he uh Whenever there was like a
courtroom sketch or classroom or like a
town hall where there's like the hubbub
before like the gavel yeah everyone's
like you know but I'm bad he'd be like
murmur
murmur Spades gay
and uh and then they couldn't find Chris
he just disappeared and they're like
what the [__] Chris it's like where's
I don't know look at they start certain
shirts in the house they can't [__]
find him and sure enough like somebody
opens the [__] door to the bathroom
like Chris
and Chris has his pants down around his
ankles he's on the toilet and he's like
this yeah he just held that position for
an hour yeah for like an hour just just
for the bit
I'm just waiting yeah been there oh [__]
of course oh funniest human being ever
unless I wasn't standing when they were
gonna play they play hide and seek in
that in the first season they played
hide and seek and the big joke was they
weren't gonna go look for hung Tran
was that his name no Hong Tran's a
different guy oh [__] what the [__] was
this from where America is coming
standing season one winner season one
yeah
it's you know varsity
he got in trouble huh I don't know let's
Circle back to the story
[Music]
so they're playing hide and seek and
they weren't going to look the big joke
because they weren't going to look for
that fan and they the cameraman follows
him he's under the the movie theater
curtain in the theater room of the house
and the cameraman's like spot the camera
knows the joke and Dad's like get out of
here
and they put a clock in the corner of
the screen and it got to be like an hour
and a half
and eventually it just comes up from
under the curtain and he's [__]
drenched with sweat and every like Rich
Voss like they're all downstairs hanging
out yeah waiting for him to [__]
figure it out an hour and a half he's
hiding and they're downstairs watching
TV and as soon as he comes down the
stairs he goes I'm never playing hide
and seek with you guys again
they just [__] exploded
[__] Voss the best he's the best
which last time I saw him he's touching
me he walks by like literally I haven't
seen him a while I go I go hey how you
doing he walks by he goes this is why my
goes coffee Double Espresso
and he comes back and I'm like I
understand it he goes a little milk too
it's a little milk whole milk if you
could French
huh so I was with him in uh Vegas and we
went to go see cookie jar in the crumbs
he was like an old Lounge act yeah it's
just a white guy from Philly that puts
different wigs on for different artists
so he's doing Tina Turner he puts a Tina
Turner wig on he's got a little Casio
that plays all of me and he's the he's
good I'm sure so we're just sitting
there it's it's me Bruce Smirnoff Mike D
Nicola and Rich Voss is there with like
a stripper he met
and vasco's listen
give me a hundred dollars
I lost all my money playing crafts but
I'm gonna get it back I go you got I
just got paid to Paris which by the way
was my people go what was your like holy
[__] I'm in Show Business moment when I
got paid into Paris on the dry erase
board I was between Chaka Khan and Tony
Bennett oh [__] it's been downhill ever
anyway gang
we're building back on Magic I'm uh
fighting a kid right now [__]
business by the time that [__] this
is building back uh so he comes back
like eight minutes later he goes give me
another 100. so I'm like you know what
you got it here's 200 then he leaves and
I see him coming and I I'm gonna give
him like thousands I just got paid like
I this is now a science experiment for
me yeah and Vos comes and he's kneeling
next to me at the table and cookie jars
on stage and we're you know we're five
feet from the stage and I swear to God
this is exactly what happened if you
don't know me by now
handcuff him to the Cherry as a [__]
sickness
you never know
that's not what happened
you're a crap table
that's what you are you're the best
you're the best Storyteller I've ever
met by me you're the best
enjoy Coco and Bert you're the best guy
you're the best Storyteller in the world
yeah I I know this too well I've done
lots of pockets with them you're the
best in the world also how many podcasts
have we done be ten thousand you need to
come back you need to come back all the
time and I'm not kidding yeah
semi-regular guest you need to be part
of the podcast I agree can you make the
studio closer to my house no but listen
yeah actually actually I would think
about evicted when I was in rehab sorry
man I would actually think about it how
close is your house where's your house
no I don't [__] I'll come back of course
[__] you're good it was my nap time
though I don't care they don't call me
Big Baby for nothing you're so
refreshing and I I
you're the most talented [__]
I've ever met you might be the funniest
natural naturally funniest person I've
ever met thanks buddy we get a boner
Brad
he's amazing I've been in this business
way too long you're talking about like
when your son heard you just saying [__]
you did what you're saying it gets even
better turn me into a spectator
and I'm usually the guy you know
you know thank you I've said seven
because I think well I don't but I I
don't want to talk yeah me neither
my son and I talk about things like you
don't realize your kids pick it it's
gonna get more fun as he evolves
mentally
in my Center in the car and these two
[__] gay guys are walking to my son
and they had sweats on and my son goes
look at these guys in their boner
sweatpants
and no more I want to save it for the
next podcast we do oh we're done now
yeah I I yeah I want to keep this I want
to keep this special no because we could
keep we gotta get him on a fight
companion there's a lot of 100 I don't
want to do your failed spin-off shows no
no no one's a big one no people listen
copper Miami just come on copy no I'm in
I'm in [__] you're great we love you Jan
Moore say more money God damn it uh you
chopping up before yes that was nice
buddy yeah thanks man I'm proud of you
yeah I missed your brother you're the
best I'm proud of you welcome I always
said Comics can be so mean to me but I
always defend Jay because he was so nice
to me when I first started he's the best
those are the people you don't forget
you and Dane Cook I love danger yeah I
love Dan I love dance nice to me I just
love I love that I'm at a certain age
where I have I've spent a lot of time
I've known you a long time and I love
you and I have I feel I weigh about Dane
I feel that way about people I've known
for this long and this strange
fraternity this [__] weird stand-up
fraternity of highs and lows and deep
lows highlights
and I can't help but let people left
you're amazing dude I love you I
remember doing it in your [__] house
back in the day my wife said that about
my ex-wife said it's the first guy I've
ever seen you quiet around I go because
he's better than I am at everything I
got like that watching Greg Fitzsimmons
once at The Improv which was so good it
was ornie Adams Greg then me for some
weird benefit half hour half hour half
hour and Greg did like this before any
recovery [__] it was I was just doing
[__] about what it's like being have a
kid and be a dad it's all crazy and
Fitzsimmons went up and was in the same
genre
But Ken Griffey Jr oh he's [__] well
I was just like killer and I just did 30
minutes of Impressions I was like I had
he took all the bullets out of my
[__] gun another killer he's I love
him well what's not to love about Greg
what's up his podcast is really
successful yeah Greg's doing his dog
yeah you guys will get there yeah yeah
thanks man all right uh no I'm in La
Jolla this weekend La Jolla comedy store
Friday Saturday Sunday so two shows
Friday two shows Saturday one show
Sunday your boys working on Sunday
though Jay's coming down to do a guest
spot all right I do a guest spot in
Belfast what the [__] really uh I got
nothing but Comedy Works uh in a month
so I'll see you at Comedy Works in
Denver my mom needs 27 June 29th June
30th July 1.
Jay Moore I love you man you're the best
do I get to plug myself of course what
do you have a website I saw the website
but I didn't see any it's under Facebook
Instagram okay Grand Rapids La Jolla who
gives a [__] do you know what well you
just have a good time if you miss his
show you're crazy
I look nothing like that
where's it at
it doesn't at the top there's a links
just go to jail.com
boom
Grand Rapids the Midtown
yeah we're going to be there you're at
La Jolla the week after me and then
Oxnard got moved so yeah I don't really
I'm you know what I regret even bringing
it up
God bless everyone love you you're the
best Japanese folding
is it looking fresh yeah I want to
apologize for
us for a mic at suplex in Philly I'm a
bit of a sneaker ahead now oh yeah so
what happens is I got the the dad New
Balance but if you see if you see this
they're designed they're designed I'm
breaking out of them see how I'm I'm
busting out yeah I'm busting so they
couldn't even contain me
um so they had to put parameters around
my foot so I'm fresh and I'm lit and
that's hard to do at 56 but I'm fresh
I'm lit and I'm off the chain
and those sneakers are so badass
buddy yeah